in this video we'll talk about the tumor
antigens it's an antigenic substance
which is produced by the tumor cells
so why tumor antigens are useful tumor
antigens are useful because they can be
serving as a tumor biomarker
so it it would Aid in diagnosis also
there are tumor Associated antigens
which are potential candidates for
promising cancer therapy let us talk
about tumor antigens in bit more details
so this is a tumor cell which has grown
in vicinity of normal cells
now neoplastic cells are self cells they
are just transformed into carcinogenic
state
and most of the antigens that are
present on the surface of tumor cells
are actually self antigens
so T Cell should not identify them as a
foreign substance
any immune response should not be worked
however
in cancer cells or in tumor cells there
are specific set of antigens which are
new or unique
and these antigens might not be a
present in a normal cell hence it can be
detected by the immune system as foreign
so potential immune response can be
generated against them so that's the
whole point of tumor Associated antigen
or tumor antigens so imagine this is a
normal cell which is expressing a self
peptide on MHC class 1
any cd8 positive T cells would not
recognize this and they should not
engage because long back due to Central
tolerance and peripheral tolerance all
self-reactive cd8 positive T cells were
eliminated from the systems and this is
a safeguard mechanism in our immune
system
but in cancer cells there are specific
antigens which might be unique or there
are some antigens which are existing
antigens but mutated
in that case those unique proteins would
be detected by the cd8 positive T
cytotoxic cells
and that would mount an immune response
again these cell types and this is what
happens in tumor so let us understand
few more scenarios in bit more details
so here in yellow you can see the normal
cells and in pink you can see the cancer
cells
so in cancer cell you might have altered
self-peptide which might have resulted
due to a mutation
that has generated a completely
different or unique peptide and now that
is presented on class 1 MHC so T cells
can recognize that and engage
in an alternate scenario you can imagine
that there are specific oncopeptides
that are not present in normal cells
and there is a inappropriate expression
of these particular peptides in this
cell type maybe these cells are only
present in fetal State and not supposed
to be present in the adult state but
somehow these cells are now expressing
this protein and that's why it is
treated as a foreign
in alternate scenario maybe there is a
self protein but now it is over
expressed or expressed in much more
quantity than it is supposed to be and
all this scenario might lead to an
immune response or recognition of these
cells as a potential immune targets
now let's talk about the classification
of tumor antigens there are two broad
categories tumor specific antigens and
tumor Associated antigens as the name
suggests tumor specific antigens are
unique to tumor cells whereas tumor
Associated antigens are normal cellular
proteins with unique expression patterns
so imagine there are there is a gene a
whose product is protein a and there is
a mutation in this particular Gena which
is oncogenic mutation as a result of
this mutation altered peptide is
generated which is now displayed on the
MHC class 1 molecule so this would
become a tumor specific antigen now
imagine a situation where a particular
cell expresses a particular protein
which is present only in the fetus now
this particular
protein should not be expressed in an
adult state but imagine in a cancer cell
this protein is expressed that means
that would this would be treated as a
potential immune Target and this is
known as tumor Associated antigens let
us take some real life example to
appreciate this better
in markets lymphoma where ipsene bar
Virus Infection has been reported the
EBV proteins are displayed on class 1
MHC molecules or on Class 2 MHC
molecules and this particular evv
proteins are treated as foreign antigens
so immune cells engage against them
in cervical cancer HPV E7 and E6
proteins are associated with cancer
progression and immunity against these
cancer cells
now there are two well-studied onco
fetal antigens which are
Alpha phytoprotein and carcino embryonic
antigen or cea
among them Alpha phetoprotein is
associated with ovarian cancer liver
cancer testicular cancer
and carcino embryonic protein or carcino
embryonic antigen is associated with
many other cancer types but in general
they are found in liver cells when the
fetus is two to six months old and it's
not supposed to be present in adults but
now it is upregulated and found in
colorectal cancer 90 of advanced
colorectal cancer and 50 percent of the
early stage colorectal cancer
shows a cea elevation in the patient
serum so it can also work like a
biomarker for detection or staging of
these cancer
and now we understand what is the
importance of tumor specific antigen or
tumor Associated antigens
I hope this was informative you can
follow our Facebook page or Instagram
page for more notes and flashcards you
can support our Channel using super
thanks
and see you in next video